good morning believe nation today's
messages take responsibility over to you
Danny Johnson so if we all have 24 hours
in a day we all live on planet Earth and
we all work what are you doing with your
time because people like a Bill Gates or
the late Steve Jobs they had lived on
planet earth they had 24 hours in a day
and they worked why is it that they made
so much more money than the rest of us
because there is a variable in the
equation of success and that variable is
you it's you not your government that
you're working under not the boss not
the business not the manufacturing not
the product not the service you and what
you do with what you have you see when I
first got started in business you know
as a homeless broke fat cocktail
waitress well the business that kind of
presented itself to me if you will was
actually sitting in my back seat it was
not something that I wanted to do but as
a cocktail waitress I knew that I'd be
homeless for another three months and I
knew it I would never pay off my $35,000
in debt making the amount that I was
making as a cocktail waitress so I came
to that conclusion
hopefully you're coming to the same
conclusion this is not gonna work I have
to find a way to generate more income
rather than waiting around for someone
to sail in and save the day yeah I had
to make some serious changes you know
and that's unfortunate because people
are struggling right now they're waiting
for someone to take the problems away
they're waiting for someone to change
the circumstances they're waiting to be
found
they're waiting for somebody to make all
the difference for them there is no
somebody actually I have to correct
myself
you are the somebody I don't think if
people take enough responsibility for
where they are in life I think it's too
easy to blame other people it's too easy
to blame your government or blame your
family for not having the right
actions are blaming your bank for not
giving you the money or you know blame
your circumstances it's too easy the
thing that you need to do the taking
responsibility is painful is painful
it's way easier to say well I'm not
successful because of this person or
this person or this person it's not
because of you
now of course not it's because of your
president that's why you're not
successful and it's not until you
actually look yourself in the mirror and
realize that there is no cavalry coming
to save the day for you you know there's
no fairy godmother coming down to grant
your every wish it's on you and you are
responsible for where you are right now
you you may not be responsible for you
know where you're born but once you
become an adult you know your ass also
for your life you can only blame your
parents and blame your upbringing for so
long where if you want to make a
dramatic change in your life you have
the power to do it and there's tons of
people who've done it and there's tons
of people who who started with way less
look at most successful famous
entrepreneurs people that you look up to
people you think now are living the the
big life you look at where they started
look at where they came from chances are
they had way less in terms of money in
terms of Education in terms of resource
and some connections than what you
already have right now the difference is
their mindset the difference is that
they took responsibility for where
they're at the difference is they said
if I'm gonna get to where I need to go
nobody's gonna hand it to me
I need to do this myself and so if you
look yourself in the mirror and you're
saying why am I not successful and
you're coming back with excuses then
that's what you need to change
I recognize that as soon as you
understand that this is on you to change
your life it's on you to build your
business and nobody's coming to save you
and that you can do it once you accept
responsibility things start to change so
the question today today is I want to
know who or what are you blaming for not
being as successful as you want to be
leaving the comments below I'm gonna
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot